there have been some troubling headlines
in the last month about the VA zero in
the opioid epidemic especially in light
of the events and Tomah Wisconsin the VA
there do you acknowledge that the VA may
have played a role in the opioid crisis
well I think the VA dating years back
was much like what was happening across
all of American health care where pills
were prescribed in many cases
inappropriately over utilized over
prescribing pain medication over
prescribing payment was happening and
right up regular hospitals and in VA
hospitals absolutely and I don't think
the doctors at the time understood the
consequences of those decisions and they
often didn't see what happened to their
patients and their families after
somebody became addicted since 2010 VA
has taken this on as a major issue
before God attention across America we
started our opioid safety initiative
then and since then we've seen a 36%
reduction in the use of opioids among
veterans I participated in the
President's Commission on opioid use and
addiction and I've come out of that
convinced we can do more and we're going
to accelerate our efforts and we're
going to be more aggressive with the
strategies that we're employing because
frankly many of these patients that are
addicted to opioids it was preventable
and we have to be looking at doing this
smarter and better and that's a
commitment that we have it the
Department of Veteran Affairs I mean can
you now look how many VA hospitals are
you in charge of well we have a hundred
and sixty-eight major medical centers
and over a thousand facilities so of
those hundred and sixty-eight VA
facilities could you order up a report
on your desk and could you see hey this
VA right here is describing a lot of
opiates I mean can you do that I
absolutely can do that and I do do that
we didn't actually bring it down to the
prescriber level but last week I was in
Coatesville Pennsylvania where they have
4% opioid use rate which is among the
lowest in the country I was in Cleveland
Ohio where they have a 5% rate among the
lowest in the country the average and
the VA systems close to 15% but there
are some that are well above that so
that's how we target our efforts and we
can actually go and do interventions
both educational and administrative to
make sure that the use rate is
appropriate so I know you've talked
about transparency as a journalist could
I go and see which hospital or facility
has the largest prescribing rate of
opiates in the country we haven't yet
posted that publicly but I think that
it's something that we could consider
doing and we try to use transparency
where where would actually be helpful in
helping patients make better decisions
and I think that that's a reasonable
suggestion